welcome to this video playing dr. Jeong
Nam always great to have a really cool
opponent one of the all-time great
players of the 80s and early 90s I
played this exchange line recently maybe
he is vaguely remembering I don't know
it's just a speculation again this you
can play me 5 i'm not but i don't know
this so well here seems to be wanted to
avoid the exchange until now we have
from we have a bin only type of position
but it's slightly tricky for black
because he didn't he didn't manage to
play ecigs and take it out playa 6 now
young hmm the question is just Bishop d3
or is there some b5 related trickery the
other is simplified related recovery
just retreat the stuff this is the
easiest against this Queen a fire phone
maneuvers Bishop t2 is often a good
response now we will manage to play six
but I don't mind that too much e takes
d5 eat XD five is a very one-sided
position where black is not having so
much fun rook e1 or Quincy to ya
coincident
can play 95 now yeah pawn takes is a
positional mistake because of a 5 this
is the kind of position realm which is
very similar to the other buck variation
it's um it's always some slight a slight
pool for white Jay this end game but
it's it's fairly solid of course for
black so how to proceed simply slowly
not simply slowly improving at the
position of core I want to get the
Queens of the board this would help get
this threatening Bishop g5 not sure
queen edge for was such a lucky such a
great move probably needs to retreat now
we should defy this quite annoying SS
Bishop f4 g3 yeah I had this this type
of position quite a number of times and
even in tournament chess and it's um
it's fairly uncomfortable for black I
think hmm really this looks strange
this looks very fishy to me mode I'm not
quite sure I'm what to do against it
hmm
it looks Sam it looks as mentioned very
fishy to me
yeah I'm not quite sure if he can at
some point play a five maybe and so
let's do this okay back sorry you missed
one move I had a phone call which I
needed to take very quickly they didn't
want to have it on tape would be weird
to to listen to my phone calls and
probably a.m. this was some I know maybe
this wasn't the greatest idea ever what
I did well it's not not like a mummy
trouble or something but I don't like it
too much now that I think of it a bit
bit deeper
yeah and let's get this piece off
ray needs to exchange and then on my
dears Queen f4 to attack d 6 it's still
not great for black that the screen is
not in a good spot it looks active but
it's not not doing so much on the edge
porn not clear what's better yeah this
is probably the the more dynamic option
yeah but now this one what are you doing
now d 6 d 6 is just attacked 98 am
probably 98 9427 something like this
okay let's do this important move the
system if this is good to fix it on
light squares mighty for now I pretty
much still in control where he cannot he
cannot move three Queenie five is not on
because c5 hangs and he's got a hard
time to to even move pieces cam should I
exchange it look so it should be good
for Wyatt but it also my turn helps to
eat some a bit of the pressure
that should really exchange would be
would be weird night f6c would would
would get Quincy Quincy 3 and its seeds
in a pen this was my idea trying to get
him in the spin mop get the kicking move
in the play before wow he just goes into
the pin
cannot really move now
hmm yeah Justin just barely defense this
time playing yeah unfortunately just the
drawn I mean position wise he can try to
win this on time now I've got Bishop c8
could have done this before maybe I had
missed this opportunity a couple of
times before not sure this is why I
needed to play this a five more thing
check
check scale me stay me know ah Stan made
no I hope I didn't kill your headphone
now I stalemate yeah the kind of kind of
free move that you can fall into six
seconds at six seconds actually a good
term yeah I probably would have managed
even he's not so quick yeah but he
somehow got out of this he got out of
this it was a very very problematic
position of course he can he can he can
just draw I mean he can take in this
position if you look at this he can just
take yeah and then stay here just for
ever and but he he was with little time
overlooking this Bishop f5 I could have
done that here and only only now saw it
this is why I needed to play this a five
move to keep the Ponzi on b7 a sick this
is the winning idea at the end to get
the bishop to see a tent and eat the
spawn but some way he got out of this
another computer yeah gives before his
winning yeah probably I thought my idea
was to play f/4g five but he's just in
time just in time with King f7 and now
it's the draw nothing to do but it could
could oops this was too quick here here
before his strong him this is very
thematic also attacking those two
weaknesses and no way he can they can't
play that but this is so very hard to
believe that you could could survive
this
yeah it's very bad for black you have
this is awful bishop against whites a
big space advantage now interesting game
thanks for watching